five-minute stafford trap recap oh
how many staffer traps can i show in
five minutes set a timer for five
minutes
okay sapphire trap number one
the legendary oh no my queen so all the
traps are gonna be from this
position uh this is like the first one
to know you take here you say oh no my
queen
someone call an ambulance but not for me
because this is checkmate
staffer trap number two if they play e5
in this position then you play knight e4
and then you you say he
and
then white will probably resign due to
your evil laugh but also due to the fact
that
i've triggered caps lock and black's
threatening f2 and if takes takes key
two eventually we're winning the queen
if takes the bishop we take the queen
that's stafford trap number two
um very similarly
if this this this we just transpose into
the same thing
so that's staffer trap number three but
uh
it's basically the exact same thing i'll
show one more line here if this we take
we check and here it takes takes lemon
material
another cool trap after e5 the best move
is d4 and then we play queen h4
threatening mate and if white plays g3
which looks very normal we take
and even though we lose a night after
takes there's this fork
and black winds material
and this is also a pin so white's
already in big trouble here
uh was that four traps
i think that was four traps
so now let's look at traps where white
plays knight c3 and there's a ton of
traps
after this move
we continue with this
uh most common trap that i think
so many people fall for
including many strong grand masters
is
knight g4
and this is already preferable for black
uh
the only way to really try and defend f2
is bishop e3 but then after takes takes
takes black won back the pawn
and has a great position
uh what else
yeah bishop bishop c4 is another like
really common trap
and then we play knight g4
and
this is already like terrible for white
a lot of players castle here and then
queen h4
hitting f2
and yeah most people play h3 over 21 000
people and then we take and then queen
f3 and then we take with double check
and then king here over here
then check again and then checkmate
so over 2300 games with this position
uh have i had this
with black
i've had this exact game six times with
black
so much fun
alternatively white can play queen f3
here but then knight e5 is a super
strong move attacking attacking and
defending
and then after queenie two there's queen
h4
uh setting up a really nice pin against
f pawn
um creating a situation where the queen
is overworked and now we're threatening
to take and then take
or take take and then take
and if g3 there's queen
here and then bishop here is coming with
invasion against f3
and if d3 there's bishop g4 and this is
just really bad for white like queen f1
i've had twice and then take take and
castle with a really nice position for
black
going back
i can show my favorite trap which is
bishop e2 and there's different
variations
which can kind of transpose like bishop
e2 or h3 can lead to the same thing
but essentially we play h5 preparing
this
and after h3 queen d4
and after castling knight g4 and this is
already winning for black
uh because there's massive uh pressure
against f2 and if white takes takes
black's running queen e5 with force
mates like if d3 black is mating in
three more moves
uh g3 there's queen g3 checkmate
f-pawn is pinned
so
white's best try is to play g3 here but
after g3 there's queen e5 king g2
and another piece sacrifice bishop takes
f2
oh no my bishop
so black sacrificed two pieces
but after rook f2 queen h5
there's really no stopping the eventual
checkmate
like if rook f4 there's this this this
and rook h1 is coming
and the funny line is if king takes f2
then rook h2
king e3 queen g3
and even though black is still down two
pieces
uh this is just really really fun for
black
and that's my five minute timer
it says done
oh there was one i missed i forgot to
show the
oh let me include one more bonus trap
we're going a little bit over time
but there's a cool trap that
should be included and this is one that
i've trapped nemo with i've also trapped
a handful of title players with is
bishop e3
takes takes knight for hitting the pawn
queen f3 and then queen g5
hitting the pawn again
the only way to defend the pawn is with
the king
after king d2 there's really cool move
knight h2
i've had this yeah five times
and after rook h2
which is actually a blunder
then queen e5
and this is winning
a rook for for black
and although we stacked the knights
black's gonna be up to exchange like
rook h5 we take
and black is um
yeah pretty much winning according to
the engine okay so that's the bonus trap
uh i hope people are satisfied